plus d'un milliers de réunionnais réunis
au pavillon des champs elysées à paris à
l'invitation du conseil départemental de
la réunion pour célébrer l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
il y à 167 en ce 20 décembre est devenu
au fil des ans un rendez vous
incontournable
une journée où les ultramarins de
métropole se retrouve dans un esprit
kabar en musique une belle fattar n'aura
effectivement l'ambiance et la musique
dans notre pays
six groupes de musique plus de 24
musiciens des danseuses al'approche de
noël l'antenne du département à paris a
une nouvelle fois célébré l'événement en
grande convivialité
c'est la cinquième édition donc ça fait
on a démarré à 300 début on est
aujourd'hui cinquième édition à plus de
11 cents
c'est dire que cette cérémonie est
importante et gagne de plus en plus
d'ampleur en train d'esquisser occasion
de réchauffer le coeur on va dire à
travers la musique
cette commémoration est aussi l'occasion
de partager un moment de mémoire pour
tous les ultramarins
les élus d'outre-mer partagent ensemble
le douloureux souvenir de l' esclavage
dans tous les outre mer nous fêtons
l'abolition les stages et
particulièrement aujourd'hui nous fêtons
l'abolition de l'esclavagé à la réunion
c'est une part de notre histoire que
nous voulons fêter aujourd'hui parce que
c'est l'événement qui a permis à nos
territoires d'outre-mer d'avancé tout
l'après-midi les invitions chanter sur
des rythmes le célèbre et ont dansé sur
des airs de maloya ou de sega magnifique
une ambiance chaleureuse ponctuée par la
loterie de billets d'avion ont été
remportés je suis très ému de pouvoir
partir à la réunion
son département
c'est une île à laquelle je suis très
attaché par une histoire de ma famille
proche entendu mon nom ben je me suis
vraiment posé la question c'est est ce
que j'entendais et 2ème fois ben là j'ai
réellement pris conscience que c'était
moi le
le gagnant de ce biais de ce billet est
ce voyage pour la réunion que j'adore
aussi l'antenne parisienne du conseil
départemental poursuit son action
métropole une nouvelle boutique à
d'ailleurs été récemment inauguré elle
connaît un franc succès grâce à ses
produits variés gastronomiques et
artisanaux via l'antenne de vie il ya
beaucoup d'artistes qui vont exposer va
l'avoir il ya beaucoup de produits de la
terre c'est plus facile d'accès au dieu
te ramène tout la valise trop lourds y
acheter à la boutique en toute fin
d'après midi les familles se sont
quittées avec un sac cadeau et un goûter
aux couleurs pays avec notamment des
letchis de la réunion
m
on
seuls 20 décembre c'est un moment en
rond peut se rassembler partager ça
permet de retrouver nos racines avec
tous les gens du pays quoi on mais
c'était une très bonne après midi on
s'est bien amusé le plaisir surtout
quand on est loin de notre île comme ça
de passer une petite après midi une
ambiance créole c'est génial merci
encore une après midi très chaleureuse
beaucoup d'ambiance et puis ça nous a
fait rappeler à peu notre pays on va
dire on retrouve un petit peu cette
ambiance locale
cette ambiance réunionnaise avec la fed
cup une abolition des clubs aujourd'hui
et le fait de retrouver un petit peu
tous les anciens copains que j'avais pas
vu depuis des années c'était l'occasion
aujourd'hui sur paris de retrouver des
anciennes têtes que je n'ai pas du tout
longtemps donc c'était vraiment sympa ça
va merci bien et me embrasse toute la
bande
allez au revoir